this is the greatest that humanity has
ever been so if you read a lot of blog
posts and watch TED Talks and other
videos on YouTube then you've probably
heard people saying that we pretty much
suck right now we're the most obese we
ever were we're the laziest we ever were
we have short attention spans
Millennials are ruining everything etc
we sit all day at work and it damages
our spine
we're in dark rooms dingy rooms which
means we aren't getting enough vitamin D
we stare at computers all day which
upsets our body clock and damages our
eyes and we don't exercise enough
because we don't have any need to and we
drive everywhere we're just these lazy
fat useless people and it's no wonder
we're all depressed and we're all
stressed and we're all ill all the time
we're getting more diseases than ever
before outside most cancer everything
this weather the worst we've ever be if
you believe the zeitgeist then we're the
worst we've ever been I'd like to put
forwards a counter-argument and suggest
that we are the best we've ever been and
we're only going to keep getting better
so yeah obviously all those things are
kind of true we do sit a lot and it
damages our spines we don't squat like
mr. poster we don't spend enough time
outside like we're supposed to we eat a
whole bunch of processed food etc I get
it there's a lot that we could
definitely improve but I think we
shouldn't focus entirely on these
negatives firstly they're not all
completely accurate for instance the
fact that we sit too close to the screen
that damages our eyes there's no actual
evidence to suggest that there's a
correlation between people sitting close
to TVs and having bad eyesight but
people now think that's probably just
because when they have bad eyesight you
stick closer to the television so you
can see it but also a lot of these other
things that are so bad for us also have
positive sides to them for instance
driving sure we drive everywhere that's
lazy it's damaging the planet not great
however driving is a fantastic thing for
our brains and just for expanding our
minds think about it with we're driving
super fast in this vehicle we have to
expect a so attentive to what's going on
on the road you have to be completely
focused we have to react quickly
we've imprinted in our muscle memory how
to use the gearstick how to indicate to
other people as we drive we're laying
down maps huge a much broader areas and
we ever would have done before so we
know that taxi drivers have particularly
heavy developed brains specifically in
the
relating to the roots they have to learn
especially London drivers I think they
have to learn this thing called the
knowledge which is all of these back
roads and things that allows them to get
around quickly and that increases the
size and the weight of their brain
because they're learning so much
information and brain plasticity tells
us that when you learn new information
you build new connections in your brain
but we're all doing this it used to be
that we would just walk around in a tiny
small community but now we drive huge
distances on a regular basis we've
mapped out so much more of the earth and
not just our own area many of us have
lived in different places I've lived in
three four five cities I can't remember
even doesn't really matter the point is
we travel all around now and that's
incredibly good for our brains and the
fact that we're driving is incredibly
good for our brains
I mean I've talked about in the past how
we should really be out there hunting
tracking prey etcetera because that uses
all the skills that our brains and
bodies are designed for us to use things
like attention being in a flow state
being aware but we do that as well when
we're driving likewise when we play
computer games computer games are
fantastic for your brain you hear so
much about how computer games are bad
for you how they're bad for your health
because you're just sitting down not
doing anything how they're bad for your
eye is like I said which isn't actually
true how they're bad for your violent in
tendencies in nature
in fact computer games are brilliant
brain training they've been shown to
improve your ability to distinguish
between light shades of grey they
improve your visual acuity because
you're scanning for objects on the
horizon they've been shown to improve
your decision-making under pressure to
help you make fast decisions better
decisions they've been shown to improve
your memory your spatial awareness even
increase lucid dreaming computer games
are learning that's why they're
addictive they press all the buttons
that our brain once causing that
dopamine release when we play a computer
game like a shooter or something we're
almost always in a kind of flow state
when was the last time you were shooting
aliens in whichever game and you notice
your mind wondering think oh I don't
know I'm going to have the tea doesn't
happen we're very focused we do that
it's almost meditative which is
fantastic and now the internet because
this is something else that gets a lot
of bad press the Internet is ruining our
attention spans is rotting our brains
it's causing us to become stupid and
lazy and all we like is cat videos
but actually the internet is also
fantastic for our brains because we
we've finally got access to all the
world's information at the press of a
button we're so much more knowledgeable
so much wiser so much more worldly than
we would have been before the Internet
we can answer any question we can pursue
any interest we watch things on YouTube
on and we Mead blog post that we'd never
would have done before I've learned so
much from Ted I've learned so much from
brain picking zorg from nerdwriter from
other fantastic YouTube channels like
like those ones like what I've learned
all of this stuff is is fantastic
and we're just filling our brains with
all this information that we never would
have done before for the first time most
of us are polymaths anyone who's got the
interest can go out there and absorb all
this information that we would never
done before and at the same time we're
communicating with people all around the
world people so different from us and
this again it expands our brains
increases it creates more neural
connections social interactions create
more neural connections this is a great
way to fend off something like
Alzheimer's if you are old and disabled
you can't move around then give someone
I padlet and chat in the forum that's
gonna do wonders for improving their
cognitive performance as they age and
it's gonna help us to broaden our mind
and to be less judgmental less
prejudiced and when you bring in foreign
ideas when you get a mixing pot of
different ideas different cultures that
really have incredible new ideas and new
discoveries and instead of just being in
school and becoming more more extreme in
your one viewpoint when you open your
mind and accept other viewpoints
that's when a you break down a lot of
the barriers of prejudice etc but be you
just create entirely new possibilities
that you're blind to before this is how
creativity works in the brain creativity
as well is supposed to be ideation it's
supposed to be greatly helped by
communicating with other people these
collaborative tools that less work
online with people all around the world
they're incredible I work for Angelo
Authority comms many of you know and we
work remotely all of us are located in
different places around the world we use
tools like slack like asana and using
these we can work with each other
anywhere in the world at any time
crossing different time zones
that's fantastic these kind of that
birth so ideas that just couldn't have
happened otherwise because we're
bridging
gap and yes whilst being able to get all
that information very quickly could
shorten your attention span we might be
not as good sitting down and reading a
long passage of text a long book but
back then that's all they had we have
access to information now and whilst
we're worse perhaps holding our
attention although I would say things
like driving my computer games mitigate
this somewhat the ability to scan for
information has improved in the ability
to quickly grab information from
elsewhere has improved we're all
polymaths now we're all pursuing
different interests rule expanding our
minds with new information that's
incredible so how are we the worst we've
ever been how are we so dumb and lazy
when actually a lot of the stuff we're
reading a lot of stuff we're watching is
really expanding our minds think of the
kind of things that people are capable
of these days from creating videos to
making apps and games speaking multiple
languages to do incredible arts and
crafts to doing mechanical engineering
on their own cars because they've got
the information online to building
electronics projects to traveling the
world to climbing mountains all these
things and so many people are not just
good at one of these things but multiple
things to get people who are fantastic
at drawing and painting but also amazing
at proposing professional music that
they sell online or taking stunning
photography that's professional standard
they do some this spare time like I say
more and more people today should
classify there's true polymath now as
for our health as for the fact that
we're apparently lazy and we apparently
eating badly sure maybe a lot of us
equal our processed foods that we
shouldn't be but we also most of us
supplementing with different things to
improve our health we're making more
mindful more conscious decisions about
these things so we're seeking out food
that we know I've got more nutritional
value a lot of us very few people are
completely blind to all this most of us
now have more information about helping
we ever did before part of the reason we
seem so unhealthy is because we're now
aware of the fact that we have been
doing things that are bad for us so go
back 20 30 40 50 years then you can see
we're unhealthy when we're smoking when
we don't realize that eating processed
sausages is not quite as healthy as
eating you know nice lean chicken and a
few eggs of course you don't need me to
tell you that we're living longer than
ever before that we're able to treat
more diseases than ever before if you
think that weren't healthy now then try
going back to a time when you
have to have a limb removed without
anaesthetic and without antibiotics try
going back to a time when we drank beer
instead of water because the water was
so polluted there's a theory in fact
that the Enlightenment happened because
we switched from drinking beer to
drinking tea and so instead of drinking
alcohol all the time we're drinking
caffeine now imagine what can happen
when we introduce safe and natural
nootropics
and start consuming those instead of
things that making us less healthy
things are amazing now they're only
gonna get much better today we're
improving our health we have much more
information than we did before on our
diet and many of us are seeking out
better ways of eating that better suit
us at the same time we're doing the same
thing for exercise
yeah we're sitting that's bad we've
always sat we now realize that we
shouldn't be sitting and we're getting
more active and meanwhile we're finding
new ways to Train we're learning more
about mobility more about strength more
about muscle fiber recruitment and all
of this is allowing many of us to train
like athletes look at old sports
competitions look at old time strongmen
look at old records we're smashing them
all the time with all this new
information and we're getting to the
point now I mean it wasn't that long ago
when nobody really worked out Arnold
Schwarzenegger in those classic early
bodybuilders helped to break Fitness
like this into the mainstream and sure
maybe the way we train has changed a bit
but before that many of us weren't doing
much at all now most of us have some
kind of health slash training regiment
and this is helping us to all be fitter
and many of us if we were to compete
with athletes from bygone eras we
wouldn't do that badly where many of us
have more tones faster stronger and the
ones that aren't at least aware that
they aren't and they know what they need
to do to fix it oh and here's something
else to think about when people say that
we're not functional anymore or we're
not adaptive that we lost our basic
human movements consider this that the
body is designed to adapt to the
stimulus you give it it's designed to
thrive on the food it's given us
designed to adapt and become physically
better whatever it is you do so when you
say you're not functional anymore
because you can't squat down to the
floor whilst lifting a heavy log over
your head consider that you are
functional just for something different
we don't do that anymore we spend a lot
of time sitting at the desk and our
bodies have adapted with functional for
sitting at a desk
and obviously not saying that's perfect
and perhaps you'd like to be better
performance and stronger and more
flexible etc all great stuff but we're
not non-functional our bodies are
amazing they adapt to what we do most
often whatever you do most often your
body becomes better at doing that so
whatever your lifestyle is right now
your body is adapted it's functional for
doing that thing at the same time sports
are fantastic for our health again
we're using our brain Sports requires
you to be switched on focused in the
flow state aware of where everyone is on
the pitch they fortune to be constantly
moving running interacting with other
people jumping kicking most of us play
some kind of sport or dance or something
dance is fantastic for you you're
learning entirely new movement patterns
constantly things like yoga are
fantastic for your flexibility there's
so many options out there and we're
healthier and stronger we're not just
polymaths of the mind many of us are
poly matters with the body pursuing
different health exercises we've got all
this information online again that we
can follow if you think all I'd like to
start yoga sure you could go to yoga
class you could also just load it up on
TV on YouTube and then do a session and
all of this is only going to get better
as well I'm sure we've had some setbacks
in recent times some steps backwards but
on the whole we're still moving in the
right direction it's only gonna get
better with time imagine what virtual
reality we'll be able to do given time
for our fitness for our brain training
imagine how much better our health will
be given time as we start to introduce
new rules imagine how much more active
we'll be as we start to realize the
importance of that and as we start to
integrate many of the things that we're
learning now about meditation about flow
States about things like the wim HOF
method when you bring all of that
together you can be healthier and
stronger than ever before and more
intelligent more switched on and in
greater flow just watch what other
people are awesome videos if you need
more evidence that well people are
awesome right now just watch anyone
who's a fantastic at parkour or feel
that Rose a video of their martial arts
tricking and tell me that we're not
healthy at least some of us that we're
not healthier and performing probably
better than we ever have done in history
it's awesome health diet will improve
supplementation will improve medicine
will improve transhumanism is probably
just around the corner and whilst that
could have some bad implications it
might also have some amazing ones so
we're only
go up from here we're only gonna improve
from here and sure I had ignored a lot
of negative things and I know I've been
very optimistic here but that's kind of
the point I just wanted to put out there
a slightly more positive spin on
everything and say hey we're not doing
so bad you're probably not so bad I'm
not so bad we're all doing pretty good
actually and depending on which corners
of the internet you look I'd say there's
a lot of hope out there so well done and
let's look forward to a brighter future
so I hope you found this video useful
and interesting a little bit different
if you did then please leave a like down
below please comment I'd love to know
what you think on this topic are we
better than ever before are we worse or
are there at least some things that are
better that maybe get downplayed because
well it's trendy to spread bad news
isn't it bad news is what people want to
read apparently let me know your
thoughts in the comments down below and
stay tuned for more videos on these
sorts of topics whether that's fitness
training transhumanism nootropics
learning etc productivity technology if
that sounds good and thanks a ton for
watching and I'll see you next time bye
for now
[Music]